navigating home ownership it's not easy
especially if you're a first-time
homebuyer despite all the challenges
hispanics continue driving up home
ownership across the nation there's
actually a new report on this and it
shows latinos in nevada accounted for
more than 47 percent of our growth in
the last 10 years hector mejia is live
this morning hector let's talk more
about this report
yeah good morning guys well analysts say
this upward trend happened even though
this is one of the most challenging
housing markets for first-time buyers in
history and there's a report by the u s
census bureau saying that during 2021
the hispanic ownership rate increased to
more than 48 percent nationally the
national association of real estate
hispanic professionals says while the
trends are positive latinos face the
following challenges they're
overwhelmingly in areas with housing
shortages like for example here in
nevada first time buyer programs saw
historic hurdles the real estate
industry lacks representation and
diversity and latinos remain the most
underinvested demographic today the
non-profit adds that by 2040 hispanics
are projected to make up 70 percent of
first-time buyers across the u.s
we are really thriving
to build wealth
through
home ownership as well and that is very
important
to understand that majority of the
american families
build wealth
through their
their home ownership over the years and
so latinos are understanding that this
is
an important piece of the puzzle for us
most recently during the pandemic a lot
of us have put additional value in being
homeowners that's one of the reasons why
the market went up instead of going down
according to local analysts and there
are first-time homebuyer programs out
there for a lot of people those programs
coming whether it's from the government
or even some banks offer their own
programs as well reporting live hector
mejia live local now